well if you're on the right then you
know that the phrase this is why we lose
has become something of a cliche these
days anytime anyone on our side does
anything we don't like we're bound to
declare this is why we lose as if that
person is now a symbol for America's
cultural Decline and in many cases the
this is why we lose charge can be off
base or at least overwrought and
overstated but not always and so today
we begin with an actual case of this is
why we lose so over the past few days
has been seemingly out of nowhere a
full-court press by some on the right to
rehabilitate budlight and to convince
conservatives to drop the boycott of the
company now we know that some notable
figures on this side of the aisle were
never on board with the boycott in the
first place famously Donald Trump Jr
defended the beer maker from the very
beginning saying that budlight is on our
side despite appearances and we
shouldn't punish them for their brief
foray into trans propaganda but Trump Jr
and others in that orbit were alone
originally um in their Pro budlight
stance at least for many months until
just now this week uh both UFC president
Dana White and Kid Rock have both
appeared in interviews with tuer Carlson
to declare that uh they they have
renewed support for budlight and some
other prominent voices like Tim P have
come out to defend that position now In
fairness to those guys we're going to go
through these clips one by one so you
can hear their arguments for your
yourself before I explain why they're
totally wrong but first here's Dana
White listen if you consider yourself a
patriot right you're a
patriot you should be drinking gallons
of Bud Light believe me when I tell you
wait wait wait I should be I should be
boycotting Bud Light gallons of Bud
Light you should have Bud Light drums
stacked up in your garage and drinking
it right out of the keg they are way
more aligned with you than most of these
other beer companies are that I
guarantee you take it from somebody
who's in the know who does business with
beer companies you are way more aligned
with Bud Light than you are with any
other beer compan I mean they didn't
come into partnership with you by
accident no obviously we had multiple
bids on the table they seek you out we
had multiple bids on the table they were
one of them and as I you know history
has shown me with relationships that
I've had with other beer companies I who
lean more this way yeah I who consider
myself a patriot don't go crazy over the
whole Pat thing but I consider myself a
proud American I'm happy to be an
American I love this country and you are
way more aligned with anheiser bush than
you are with other beer companies now
I'll have plenty to say about the thrust
of Dana's arguments after we play all
the clips but I do want to point out one
thing right away um budlight is a brand
owned by a foreign conglomerate so
putting everything else aside it's very
hard to make the case that it's
patriotic to support a foreign company
now I'm not saying that we can't support
foreign owned Brands after all that's
most brands I'm just saying that it's
hard to cast your support for a Belgian
multinational corporation as
patriotic but we'll get back to Dana's
point in a moment first here's Kid Rock
also uh with Tucker a day later agreeing
with Dana and echoing a lot of the same
sentiments
watch I think it could be I think they
got some work still to get you know some
of that base that they lost I think to
get them back like you know I've said a
few times I'd like to see him get Triple
fratty like hit it head on kind of make
light of the situation self-deprecation
you know but um you know at the end of
the day when you step back and look at
it like yeah they deserved a black eye
and they got one they made a mistake how
did you know you you moved so fast on
that I mean a lot of things going on I
was like a lot of people just pissed me
off I was and I kept you know I keep a
lot of beer on the property a lot of
light beer the Bud Light was one of them
and uh I was like I know who my
consumers are I was do a little
marketing to my folks you know it was
spot on for me but also a fun excuse to
get my machine gun out and have some fun
but also to make a statement like hey a
lot of us aren't cool with this you know
I believe a lot of people fought and
died for people's right to be whoever
they want but when you're that type of
brand you know who you consumers are you
know how this kind of started I think I
thought about is they moved part of
their Corporate Offices from St Louis to
New York City yeah they did okay then
they start hiring these ivy league
Progressive you know people to work for
them who don't know about workingclass
people or Middle America in this country
women yeah and so somebody wasn't
watching the hen house they're riding
high and mighty as number one and a fox
gets in yes it was a mistake so do I
want to hold their head underwater and
drown them because they made a mistake
no I think they got the message like
hopefully other companies get it too but
you know at the end of the day I don't
think the punishment that they've been
getting at this point fits the crime
it's like I would like to see people get
us back on board and become bigger
because that's the America I want to
live
in now now many people myself certainly
included have found that uh Kid Rock's
reasoning here is less than compelling
but Tim P thinks that we're all missing
the point and uh here's the way that he
sees it listen we find ourselves at a
Crossroads do we lament Kid Rock and
Dana White in their support for budl I
mean Kid Rock coming out and saying this
he's effectively ending the boycott at
least as it pertains to him not to you
and my position we talked about this in
great yesterday is that we should take a
PR Victory declare Victory and that's it
we won but there are many people who are
calling for the destruction of budlight
as a brand They Say Never Again others
say I will drink a budlight but only
when they apologize now my argument I
would say is substantially more tactful
and less emotionally satisfying but I
agree with Kid Rock and I agree with
Dana White but more importantly I agree
with sha
Strickland the big move came when Dana
White accepted a massive sponsorship
deal from Bud Light to the tune of $105
million many of us were very upset about
this we said why are you accepting money
from this company that got woke went
broke and continues to sponsor Pride
events well of course Dana White said
you know we're going to take the money
it's the best deal ever blah blah blah
Sean Strickland MMA champion said budl
is now sponsoring everything I say and
then he went off to say a whole bunch of
anti-woke things and I like it I think
he's right at first I thought he was
wrong I thought these people were all
selling out but then I listened to what
Shawn had to say and I realized he
flipped the script he inverted The
Narrative on Bud Light and budlight has
not condemned him and that is my friends
a tremendous
Victory okay now before I explain why
this is all horribly wrong let me Begin
by stipulating that I like all these
guys I like Dan White Kid Rock Tim pool
show is great I like him personally I'm
obviously a huge fan and supporter of
tuo Carlson I think he's one of the most
important voices in the country right
now but the budlight boycott is still on
and let me explain why Bud Light the
foreign-owned
brand tried to push trans ideology it's
spat in the face of its own customers
and for once in our lives for once ever
in modern American history conservatives
fought back in an organized competent
effective way we organized a boycott we
stuck with it we actually made the woke
Company Feel the Pain we imposed our
will in a way that conservatives have
never been able to do
ever the Bud Light boycott is by far and
it's not close the most effective
conservative boycott of a major company
ever of all time there isn't even a
close second what's second place there
isn't a second place in fact I think
it's fair to say that it it's not just
the most effective but actually the only
successful boycott we have ever
staged the holidays are rapidly
approaching but we can find peace and
calm in the craziness of the season with
hallow the number one Christian Prayer
app in the world immerse yourself in
Christmas and Advent prayers meditations
and peaceful Christian music uh Hall
also offers an extensive library of
Bible reading plans accompanied by
insightful Reflections and Audi guided
meditations whether you're a seasoned
Bible reader or just starting your
journey hallow provides a platform for
you to engage with scripture like never
before a great place to start is uh with
the uh with father Mike schmitz's Bible
in a year in which he offers brief daily
readings and Reflections available on
the Hallow app Hall app also helps you
connect with a community of like-minded
individuals sharing experiences insights
and encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth this Christmas join
Hallow's Christmas prayer challenge
Advent with CS Lewis for the 25 days
leading up to Christmas you can focus on
the real reason for the season with
prayer meditation and Christmas music on
hallow download the app for free at
hall.com
Walsh for 3 months free that's hall.com
mat Walsh so we'd have to have a very
compelling strategic reason to end this
one single successful boycott campaign
ever we would have to have extracted
some kind of major
concession but what concession have they
made they gave Dana White $100 million
so what
that's not a concession that's not an
apology that's a marketing
Ploy are we going to end the Bud Light
boycott and start giving them our money
because we like their new marketing
plan that would not be be Us ending a
boycott victoriously that would be a
retreat it would be the very definition
of snatching defeat from the jaws of
Victory something that right that the
right does very often but never as
egregiously empathetic as
this and by the way if they gave $100
million to like a some kind of dtrans
fund that would be one
thing but why why would giving a $100
million to Dana White why would we
consider that to be sufficient oh you
push trans ideology and we're mad at you
for that but you gave $100 million to
the guy who owns UFC so therefore it's
okay
what there's no what's even the
connection Dana White is not a victim of
ideology he's not affected by
it if you give a $100 million to the
actual victims of this Insidious insane
uh uh depraved ideology that you were
pushing give them $100 million then I
would say yeah that okay that's an
apology a big
one giving it to
UFC who gives a damn why would that
matter to
us why would we find that to be an
acceptable
substitute now I do agree that any
boycott campaign you know with any
boycott campaign you need to give
companies an out you have to give them a
way to get back into your good graces
the whole point of a boycott is that
you're withholding support in order to
extract some kind of concession so at
least in theory there should be like
something that they can do that would
make you not mad anymore and if you get
the concession then you win and if you
don't get the concession and the company
is just destroyed then you win that way
too and so far we're winning the second
way budlight betrayed its customers it
has not conceded defeat it has not
apologized at
all and and so at this point the entire
company is basically in
shambles so be
it what can budlight do to get out of
this what is there
out well they would need to apologize
for pushing transgenderism they would
need to apologize specifically
and
explicitly they would need to gravel at
our feet in humiliating
fashion and disavow gender ideology
entirely okay they would need to say we
are sorry for pushing trans ideology we
shouldn't have done it it's a terrible
thing please forgive
us that's what they would have to
do they have not done that they refuse
to do that instead they're hoping that
they can simply change the subject but
it Chang of subject is not a concession
it's not an apology it's a trick a
gimmick a diversion
tactic if we fall for it then we deserve
to lose we deserve everything that's
coming here's the
point if you're boycotting a company and
demanding some kind of
concession and you don't get the
concession and then you back down anyway
you lose you have taken your Victory and
traded it in in exchange for a defeat
you have said no thanks I'd rather not
win I'll take a loss
instead that's what it would be to start
supporting Bud Light now they have an
apologize they haven't
conceited so screw them let them wither
and die let their brand destroy itself
Let It Burn I don't
care well what are we feeling sorry for
them oh but I feel so bad for that poor
multinational foreign
conglomerate no I don't they get what
they've chosen
it's what they've chosen it's what they
get unless we decide to bail them out
because we don't have the stomach to
fight the culture War like Wars need to
be
fought you know this is part of part of
the pitch from guys like Dana White and
Kid Rock seems to be a call for some
sort of weird sort of
mercy and i' I've even seen some on the
right arguing that we're called as
Christians to forgive budlight for their
transgressions and yes that's an actual
argument I've seen from more than one
person but fighting back against culture
rot fighting back against the people who
are deliberately injecting perversion
and moral Insanity into our culture
fighting against the corporate
overlords behind all of this okay that's
not a time for
Mercy these are not homeless starving
people on the street who need a helping
hand they are Mega billion dollar
corporations who are selling degeneracy
for
profit and if you manage to get your
foot on one of their necks
you keep it
there you have no mercy until they
gravel and beg and do exactly what you
demand that they
do just like the left that's how the
left responds in situations like
this and again if we are not willing to
do that if we are not willing to be
ruthless if we will allow ourselves to
be paid
off then there's no hope
I mean we'll never win this war and we
won't deserve to win it
anyway keep in mind that the
significance of the budlight boycott and
the whole strategy behind it is that we
have made this company into a cautionary
taale you know the whole point was to
put its head on a spike on the edge of
town as a warning to others it's a
trophy for the mantle we want to show
Corporate America that this is what we
will do this is what we are capable of
doing and willing to do if you spit in
our face the way that budlight
did but if we just put a dent in their
sales for a couple of quarters get no
apology or concession at all then go
back to supporting them we'll have taken
their head off of the spike and put our
own on it instead because we will have
sent a very different kind of message to
Corporate America we will have shown
them that we're not willing to go for
the kill
shot that ultimately we always come
crawling back
pathetically with our Tails between our
legs
that ultimately all we care about is
more than anything is being consumers
and will always be loyal you know
trained puppies as
consumers will always come
back we always come back to the feeding
Bowl but you know what's happening now
is even worse because this is not just
an effort to end the Bud Light boycott
this is an effort to actively
rehabilitate their brand for them
because the truth is that you know the
boycott this is not really even a
boycott anymore it's worse than that for
budlight the problem has
metastasized we didn't just boycott the
company we rebranded it so the brand
itself now is seen as lame effeminate
embarrassing even people who don't care
about the boycott or only dimly aware of
it even they avoid drinking Bud Light
just because they don't want to get made
fun of by their friends
that's why budlight is in such a dire
situation so even if we officially ended
the boycott it wouldn't necessarily
matter because the brand is lame now
customers don't want to be associated
with
it which means that to really end the
boycott we would have to revitalize and
repair budl light's brand for them which
is what the Dana whites and Kid Rocks of
the world seem to be trying to do so
this is like declaring victory in a war
accepting your enemy surrender
and then proceeding to give them back
all the land you
gained you're not just ending the war in
that case you are actively forfeiting
your own
gains you aren't just letting your enemy
bow out you're helping them repair the
damage they caused
themselves why would we do that why
should
we what do we gain I know UFC gains $100
million good for them but what about the
rest of us what about what about the
movement what about the
culture what do we get out of this
Mercy all the conservatives I see online
and there's and there's plenty of them
we're saying oh no they give $100
million to to UFC what the hell do you
get out of that what does your family
get out of
it what about your children who you
that's what this is really about isn't
it the people that are pushing this
Insanity onto a culture that our
children have to live
in does that become better now because
UFC got some money what the hell is
wrong with you have some
self-respect and on top of it all you
know what it has to be said like
budlight sucks anyway it's a bad product
it tastes like stale rainwater scooped
out of a murky puddle on the pavement
this is not just the most effective
conservative boycott in history it's
also the
easiest because nobody with functioning
taste buds has any desire to drink that
sludge anyway so that's what it comes
down to we can do what is effective what
is right and also what is at the very
same time
easy which is to not drink
this or we can go out of our way to
kneecap ourselves and turn an easy
Victory into a laborious cumbersome
defeat those are your
options and really you should not have
any trouble making the right choice here
if You' like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there godp speed